now I've been sort of as I come round to
you I've been looking at your graphs
with the mixed levels of satisfaction so
I want you to keep that in your mind as
a warning when you draw this okay
because usually the worst thing that
will happen when the shape of your
chemistry graph is bad is that I'll
stand over you and say the shape of your
history graph is bad but here if your
shape is bad you're gonna be in real
trouble you'll see why in a minute
I'd like you to draw y equals cos
inverse okay I'm treating causing this
very deliberately let me just
concentrate while I do this properly
okay there we go that's reasonably
accurate does that look like about 45
degrees then this cos inverse okay now
I'm gonna draw the area that I'm
interested in here I don't want you to
have a think about it for a minute
I'm sorry I'm off with an angle a little
bit okay hmm
so consider with me now I gave you a
nice tie here didn't I
I am very purposefully not choosing a
nice value there okay now already giving
you a couple of clues I have told you
there is some symmetry here I told you
you can compare to the original trig
functions I want you to have a go okay
see if you can work out what kind of
solution you want to expect from that
think about the approaches that we've
already demonstrated today as you come
with an answer call me over know how
long let's think about this I did say I
did say so you have these two things to
look out for okay and I'm going to use
both of them now what did I do here well
I do you I thought about it in terms of
sine X because I know what sine X is
about and then I can do sort of um what
I do here this subtraction of areas
think about rectangles that'll work
okay so just for the sake of it let's
see what we get if we take this compare
it to what it should look like if I do
the original cos graph okay and then
well let's see where that leads us okay
now for the sake of um this particular
question and the values that I've chosen
I've gone around on how to look at all
of your diagrams I don't think I've seen
a single one big enough to actually
accurately do what I'm about to do and
make sure that you get all of the pieces
okay it is fiendishly difficult so watch
okay it's not quite the size of any
circle maybe it is well anyway okay I
want cos x okay this is from naught to
PI so I'm going to do this from naught
to PI
you're like that's too big
how am I gonna fit that on my page well
when you see what we have to do with
this you think actually I want it to be
out sighs I'm gonna go from there's one
two-thirds one-third done yeah there
okay so I always shade it just yet but
you can see in here huh that's the area
that I'm interested in in the middle
just like this is in the middle okay now
how am I going to dice this thing up
with appropriate integrals this is
kha'zix
isn't it okay well think about it piece
by piece for instance let's just look at
this top half first okay if I didn't
tell you about this bottom bit and just
asked you to work out what that area was
like before in history or anything what
would you do well you'd say there's a
rectangle here isn't there right and I
can I can handle rectangles okay we know
what the height is what is the width hmm
now here's where your inverse trig is
actually useful because the value here
is some angle that when you take COS of
n a coup you get 1/3 namely the COS
inverse that's what we define the
inverse trig functions to be okay great
so I have an area in here let's start
with that area equals and I have a
rectangle now what about this next bit
in here this part what's that equal to
well there's a cavity here isn't there I
mean I know it looks triangular hear it
but that's just because of scale okay so
being that it's curvy I need an integral
of some kind I'm going to add an
integral
what will the lower bound be it'll be
that stuff right from cos inverse of 1/3
up to now where's the interval ends
what's that point that's pile too isn't
it okay from there to plan two of
closets okay that's that's not too bad
but I only have half the area okay
how do I deal with this guy down here
well I can work out that that's another
rectangle is it what's the area of that
rectangle it's 130 per unit high and
it's PI on two units one I can work that
out now that's PI on six isn't it
one six units okay all right now I've
got this guy to deal with now be careful
be very careful
this is Kurds again isn't it right so
when you do an integral you don't get
this area because that's not bounded to
the axis if I were to integrate from
here to here integral from PI onto up to
what what is this value having it it
corresponds to this doesn't it it's cos
inverse of negative 1/3 right afraid you
get from there to there of cos x what
area will I get I will get this area
okay but I want that area right so I
think that's okay
I had this problem before I'll do it by
subtraction okay I have a rectangle
there okay so hold on what's the area of
this rectangle it's a one set of units
right one set of a unit hi how wide is
it it's cos inverse of negative 1/3
minus PI on two that's the area of the
rectangle now the thing is think about
this integral think about where it is is
this positive or negative this is
negative so I need to add it is that ok
it's actually going to subtract from
this rectangle if I add it good
my brain is melting down at this point
okay great there you go
face your answer have fun okay
now you're right you're right to laugh
at this okay because it is a disaster
right it's it's four different areas
clearly there must be a better way to do
this right now what am I going I have
approached this by way of the original
trig functions that is what I have done
and it's a valid approach you'll get a
right answer to this okay I believe it
some one point earth four or something
something something okay but the
question is is there a more efficient
way and the answer is yes by using the
other thing you need to think about
symmetry now just don't worry about this
original graph for a second and this is
where the quality of your graph and its
size will be decisive there is symmetry
here it's just hard to see then when we
had the sign you know were they were
equal they were equally you know obvious
right one was sorry one was negative one
was positive very easy to see the reason
why this is hard to see is because the
symmetry is with something that isn't
there right let me make it a little
clearer for you okay
I could take either of the sections it
I'll take this one over here there's an
area there okay I'll shake it for you
and it's symmetrical to part of the area
that I want which part can you see it
now that I've shaded it can you not see
that it's equal to this area you just
need to rotate it around this point and
you get the area so being that this area
is the same as this area right all I
have to do is this I say the integral
from negative to a third of cos inverse
well it's equal to all rectangles what
is its width
it's 1/3 of a unit that's 1/3 of a unit
isn't it what is its height how high
what's the range of Cosima's
it's PI units sweat okay which by the
way is approximately 1.0 for now by the
way that's that's kind of cool right but
you're not finished yet that's not
sufficient when we use this symmetry
argument before symmetry is not enough
because as we said there's lots of
different kinds of symmetry
what symmetry is here is it an odd
function no is it an even function
this guy was but the way we restricted
this guy he's not not odd
he's not even but he has some kind of
symmetry how would you express it I even
gave you the word tonight I said this
blue area here you could rotate it
around to get this area this is
rotational symmetry so I would say as
cos inverse has rotational symmetry but
it doesn't just have any rotational
symmetry where is it rotating about you
have to retain about a point don't you
what's that point that's that's 0 pi
onto isn't it you do have to specify but
you think about it odd and even
functions they are also reflection on
rotational symmetry just there happens
there around the origin right but you
can still have symmetry around different
places it's just a bit harder to see ok